c'est le début de la campagne de chasse
pour gagner sa vie font chasse la chauve
souris écureuils un mets très apprécié
dans la région
ces lamelles de bambou vont lui servir à
fabriquer des flèches
car ici l' arme de prédilection c'est
l'arbalète dans la vallée peu de
personnes possèdent une arme à feu les
cartouches sont bien trop chers c'est
comme ça qu'on porte une arbalète
elle doit être bien collé le long du
corps pour ne pas s'accrocher dans les
buissons
on doit pouvoir courir facilement après
le gibier
pour ne laisser aucune chance aux
animaux de s'en sortir
les chasseurs vont induire leurs flèches
de poison
le poison que l'on va utiliser et pure
jean
il provient d'une fleur que l'on écrase
récoltés dans la montagne au printemps
cette plante séchée est extrêmement
toxiques avant de la manipuler les
chasseurs ont fait attention à n'avoir
aucune plaie sur les mains quand le
poison atteint sa cible
il n'y a pas de réaction immédiate mais
dix minutes après même légèrement touché
l'animal s'effondre il n'a aucune chance
d'en réchapper
il nous suffit de le ramasser
une préparation à la chasse longue et
minutieuse
pendant que ses amies termine de
fabriquer les flèches phong part en
éclaireur
c'est lui qui a la charge d'ouvrir le
chemin qui mène à leur cabane de chasse
[Musique]
la machine doit être parfaitement
aiguisé pour le reste du parcours
trois heures de marche dans une jungle
saturé d'humidité
[Musique]
voilà enfin sur le trajet on a repéré
des chauves souris écureuils
c'était par la tuer surnom ces arbres
oui j'en ai vu plusieurs
alors on commencera la chasse par ce
point mais phong est inquiet il y a trop
d'humidité dans l'air ce qui dérègle les
arbalètes les cordes se détendent et
elles perdent de leur puissance mais
surtout le bois gonfle et les arbalètes
perte aussi de leur précision
mais tant elle n'est plus très précise
mais ça va aller dans la jungle
il existe toutes sortes de bêtes
d'insectes d'invertébrés plus ou moins
dangereux comme cette sangsue qui une
fois sûr vous ne peut s'enlever qu avec
du sel mais pour les animaux mortels
comme les serpents font qu'à un produit
miracle qui est censé les éloigner on
rails or c'est un répulsif 200 mètres en
coin sur le corps un produit issu de la
médecine chinoise
hier d'autres ici il ya des serpents
venimeux il t'emmerde tombera tout
entier pourri en quelques minutes et
beaucoup de gens se font mordre
oui beaucoup trop souvent
l'idéal est d'appliquer le produit à
même la peau mais ça brûle et surtout ça
pue et accueillant
19 heures la chasse commence
pouvoir en vivre le groupe de chasseur
doit tuer une trentaine de chauves
souris écureuils par soirée
elles sortent j'en ai vu une là-bas
animer les nokia
on y va
pour attirer les chauves souris
écureuils phong imite le cri de la
femelle
mais la lumière des lampes attire le
danger regarde le serpent il énorme
recul
fais attention ce soir les chasseurs
devront rester sur leurs gardes
alors
alinghi va voir plus bas
non
est clair ici est clair ici vite il y en
a une dans cet arbre
babbitt voir regarde si tu l'as eu
moi j'y vois rien on l'a loupé mauvaise
nuit pour phong et son équipe
cette sangsue sera leur seul trophée
il leur reste encore quinze jours de
chasse pour atteindre leur quota de 500
chauve souris écureuils